in the next part of this story there's
some parallels with Abraham and and
that's built into the narrative I think
because Isaac is Abraham's descendants
and so we have to keep the narrative
echoing forward otherwise it loses its
its continuity and there's a famine in
the land that Isaac sin and God tells
him to stay the course
anyways repeating the promise he he gave
to Abraham
although Isaac goes to Abimelech also
telling the king and people that Rebekah
was his sister
which is exactly what Abraham did when
he went to Egypt and so there's another
echo there of the same the same it's as
if the story is being told for a second
time essentially and that's supposed to
remind you of the of the previous story
but they're careless the King sees that
Rebekah and Isaac are intimate together
and luckily he doesn't have them put to
death he just tells everybody in the
kingdom that they're to be left the hell
alone
and then Isaac prospers in that land
just like Abraham did in Egypt until the
Philistines ask him to leave he's just
getting too rich and powerful things are
going too well for him so he's asked to
he's asked to leave now in the meantime
Esau gets married Anna this is a funny
little story he says he marries two
women who give grief to Isaac and
Rebekah
so they who every so marries they're not
popular with his with their in-laws not
in the least that actually becomes
relevant a little later because they
drive Rebekah quite mad so I get a kick
out of that because that's very common
you know it's not easy to integrate new
people into your family and and hope
that that will go smoothly it's actually
one of the real catastrophes in life
right you have a kid and maybe you get
along with them and maybe you don't but
let's assume you do but then they marry
someone that you just don't like and or
maybe you think is wrong for them I mean
that's really rough that's what are you
gonna do about that you know because
you're you're basically screwed both
ways if you have the person you love
around then you have to put up with this
trend is creature that they allied
themselves with and if you if you get
rid of them completely well then you
know you don't have your child anymore
so it's
very very difficult position and so
that's another example of the realism I
think of the stories now Isaac who's
hypothetically on his deathbed asks Esau
to hunt for venison because he likes
venison and he's happy that his son is a
hunter and Rebekah over here is this
and so she conspires with Jacob to to
slaughter two small goats and make his
father some stew because he wants Esau
to make him stew out of venison but
Rebecca who's being I would say let's
say slightly deceitful or horribly lying
that would be more accurate
she conspires with Jacob so Jacob kills
two little goats kids and boils up a
stew and then he puts on some goat skins
because Esau was a hairy character and
and Rebecca dresses Isaac in esau is
clothing because Isaac can't see very
well at this point and so then Jacob
goes into his father with the stew and
he's trying to disguise his voice but it
doesn't work very well and so Isaac asks
him to come close and Jacob puts out his
arm with the goat skin on it and and
Isaac smells him too and he smells like
he so and which maybe wasn't the best
thing but and feels like him and and so
because Isaac thinks he's on his
deathbed he decides to deliver a
blessing - hypothetically - Esau and so
but it's Jacob and so that's a big deal
- because the blessing is actually as I
said before with these ancient people it
appeared his though once you said
something you didn't get to take it back
you couldn't say well look you've you
deceived me so it doesn't count it was
like they weren't maybe as as what week
might be one way of thinking about it
but another way is they weren't quite as
attentive to context you know because if
I make you a deal and then it turns out
that you've betrayed me I may feel that
the deal is no longer valid because the
assumption was you were being honest to
be given within that you know violates
the whole spirit but that isn't how
these people thought they said once he
promised man you promised and that was
that
so Isaac blessed Jacob he says that God
give you the dew of heaven and the
fatness of the earth and plenty of corn
and wine let people serve you and
nations bow down to you be lord over thy
brethren that's gonna be rough on me so
let thy mother's sons bow down to the
cursed be everyone that curseth thee and
blessed be he that blesseth thee and so
there's a quite a remarkable painting of
that
so there's Rebekah she's looking pretty
old and Isaac's looking pretty blind and
Jacob's taking directions from his
mother and we might say he's perhaps a
little old to be taking moral lessons
from his mother especially given how
she's acting and so it's a pretty ugly
scene altogether especially that we also
know that Jacob already tricked Esau out
of his birthright and so now he's like
taking the birthright and he's taken the
blessing and so as I said that Jacob he
turns out to be the father of Israel
it's like he's a reprehensible character
these are major-league betrayals that
he's engaging and it's not trivial he
really really pulls the rug out from
under his brother and you know you could
say well Esau is not as awake as he
might be you know he's kind of a wild
man and fair enough but it certainly
seems to me that the the predominant
moral error falls on Jacobs shoulders
it's very treacherous behavior what he's
doing so then he saw shows up and he's
got a nice stag for his dad and it's
like little late for that and he states
that his brother was rightly named Jacob
which means supplanter because he's been
deceived twice and Isaac says Isaac
answered he's asking fun es I was asking
fundamentally if there's anything at all
left over for him and Isaac can't give
him the same blessing because that's
already been given so he has to think of
something else and Isaac says behold
I've made him die Lord and all his
brothers I've given to him for servants
which includes you and with corn and
wine have I sustained him and what shall
I now do unto thee my son and Esau said
unto his father have you even one
blessing for me my father and blessed me
also and an e so lifted up his voice and
wept and you know we already know that
he saw as a
tough-guy by all appearances and you
know he's out there hunting on his own
and camping and it's like he's no
pushover and the fact that this reduces
him to tears is an indication of the
magnitude of the betrayal and Isaac says
behold thy dwelling shall be the fatness
of the earth and of the dew of heaven
from above and by thy sword thou shalt
live and thou shalt serve your brother
and it shall come to pass when you will
have the Dominion and you'll break the
yoke his yoke off from thy neck and Esau
hated Jacob because of the blessing
wherewith his father blessed him and
Esau said in his heart the days of
mourning for my father are at hand then
I will slay my brother Jacob so
fundamentally you know if Isaac dies or
when he dies then we'll mourn for him
and then Jacob better look the hell out
because it's like it's it's serious
death coming his way